hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein baby update denn sie es
jetzt schon sechs monate an
nicht ich bin raus genug zu erzählen
ich habe wieder ein paar fragen von euch
zu sammeln möchte ich einfach so ein
bisschen erzählen wie sailor geht und ja
wie sie sich entwickelt also wie gesagt
sie ist seit dem 24
april sechs monate alt ich weiß nicht
aber irgendwie verging die zeit
superschnell also irgendwie von woche zu
woche wird sie immer größer und aktiver
und man merkt es so irgendwie gar nicht
woran ich es immer merkel sind die
kleider also ihre kleidung muss ich
jetzt wieder aussortieren
ich habe sondern seine box gemacht so
ein null bis drei monate
und jetzt muss ich eine box machen drei
bis sechs monate so geht es mir übrigens
auch sein unsere hochzeit ich muss auch
nur kleider aussortieren jedes jahr muss
sich aus so 14.15 uhr das duell als in
gelenken
ja aber ich habe noch die ganzen kleider
von samira deswegen muss ich jetzt hier
das und wechsel machen große kleidung
kleidung kleidung weg und so weiter
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wie
viel wiegt und wie große ist weil die
nächste untersuchung erst in ein paar
wochen wieder ist also ich hatte also
ich hab so setzte sich locker sieben ja
oder ja so süß so lange haare bekommen
jetzt hat dieser zeit zöpfe und die ela
sieht wirklich aus wie samira original
aus dem gesicht geschnitten
nur hat er einfach mehr haare aber so
dickel der gesichtsausdruck die großen
augen hat sie alles von ihrer schwester
und ich finde es sehr aktiv also samira
war als baby integer und diana jetzt
schon sehr aktiv deswegen ist sie auch
direkt aus ihrem baby bei stellt daraus
gewachsen weil
ihre freundin die partner noch ein kilo
isst schläft ja ab und zu wenn wenn wir
mit unseren freunden zusammensitzen
dann nehmen sie auch ihr baby mit und
dann legen wir abends die kinder hinter
in ihr großes bett und luisa ihr kleines
in das kleine baby bay
und da kam mir das gitter davor machen
und da passt sie noch rein die ma aber
nett weil sie sich nach zahlt eigentlich
schon drehen will
also die ich auch nachts sehr aktiv
morano bekommst du es irgendwie nie
wieder
die dreht sich dann und einen baum den
rücken rücken auch nette nachbarschaft
zum schlafen da sind das kann sie jetzt
ungefähr seit einer woche also dass es
sich so richtig dreht die ganze zeit du
legst du dann irgendwie im wohnzimmer
auf die spielerdecke auf dem boden und
dann plötzlich irgendwo unter dem regal
ja und wir hören könnt erzählt sie auch
ganz schön viel und sehr laut und
mittags schläft sieht mittlerweile nicht
mehr so viel
die letzten drei tage sowieso war ganz
furchtbar und ich glaube sie hat gerade
wieder mit ihren zähnen da hat sie
nämlich die deutschen drei tage mittags
oder den ganzen tag über vielleicht nur
eine halbe stunde geschlafen und männern
und das war halt echt schlimm weil sie
dann echt den ganztag nur gemeckert hat
und ich glaube aber das sind die zähne
sie hatte schon zwei zähne bekommen vor
ein paar wochen und sie hat jetzt kein
fieber oder zu bekommen aber man das
gemerkt hat schon zu kämpfen und hat
immer durch die windel das ausgelassen
als wenn du was ich meine
fünf oder sechsmal am tag in folge
das weiße ballett war das entwickelt ja
wahnsinn oder gar nicht mit ja genau da
hat mir meine nachbarin empfohlen weil
ihre tochter auch schon warnt obwohl sie
auch erst drei monate altes und bei ela
hat ja auch so früh angefangen dass man
so einen
heißes falschen kurs mit weichen wurzeln
nimmt
australien ist natürlich ist genau und
da kannst du dran lutschen und ja das
beruhigt sie so ein bisschen und nimmt
glaube ich den schmerzen bis am hals
also noch schneller kettet das bekommt
man in jeder drogerie ab anna und ja ab
und zu muss man halt dann abkochen und
dann kann man es ihr wieder geben
also wirklich super tipps ja was soll
ich noch erzählt ich habe eigentlich war
auch nicht schlecht wo ich bin vom
freund bekommen
jedes dieser schnitt lustig ja ich
stimme dir ja immer noch also ich habe
jetzt sechs monate voll gestillt und
habe jetzt letzte woche ich glaube am 24
oder so angefangen mit der beikost habe
jetzt erstmal karottenbrei gegeben und
er hat erst ein paar mal wollte nicht
wirklich sie muss erst mal gucken was
kommt da überhaupt in den mund muss man
ausprobieren und vorgestern hat sich
sehr gut gegessen da war aber samira
auch mit dabei und die samira hat auch
parallel gegessen und dann hat sie eben
immer zugeguckt und hat es dann auch
gemacht und dann nimmt sie halt immer
schön den löffel und versucht dann
selber zu essen das ist echt schön und
ich werde jetzt heute dann doch den
stuhl an einem fuß auf den schnurbaum
runde zu werfen
ja ich werde jetzt heute mit karotten
kartoffel noch mit dazu geben und so
langsam eben die mittagsmahlzeit
vollständig machen und dieser dann
vollständig wenn sie eben gemüse
kartoffel
gemüse kartoffeln fleisch mit dabei hat
und fett und dann kann man die das
mittags stillen sagen geht man durch die
nahrung also durch denn durch die
beikost ersetzen
am liebsten isst sie glaube ich dass
falk bleibt der stadtapotheke neulich
hatte murat auch sehr aufpassen müssen
dass ich mal in ruhe duschen kann und
mich fertig machen kann
und als ich zurückkam hat sind din a4
papier gegessen und zwar richtig
gegessen war kein bedrucktes papier
man muss aufpassen ist ein kleiner
büchern herum
aber ich muss sagen sie ich kein
morgenmuffel also die samira die schweiz
grad fünf und zehn morgens schon
ziemlich ich würde fast sagen mach das
gerne
ja also soviel zu den schlaf und wach
gewohnheiten nachts muss ich ja auch
noch stellen manchmal einmal manchmal
zweimal muss man auch gar nicht also es
kommt immer darauf an wie sie ins bett
kommt ich versuche abends immer so um 19
30 20 uhr ins bett zu bringen
zurzeit hat auch mal nicht geklappt weil
sie dann irgendwie ja sonntags in diesen
tagen zu ende schauen möchte
januar zum 22 oder klappt ja was wollte
ich noch erzählen also ansonsten wie
gesagt stell dich sehn uhr und mittags
jetzt eben die die mittagsmahlzeit wobei
die noch nicht komplett ist und ich sind
danach auch immer noch fertig stellen
muss und dann versuchen wir so langsam
dass zu ersetzen aber ich möchte hat
noch schon noch ein bisschen stillen
wobei das problem ist beim stillen also
ich mache es echt gerne abermalig hat
auch nicht so flexibel ich mein wenn ich
irgendwo unterwegs bin ich stehe auch in
der öffentlichkeit ich bedanke mich dann
halt immer unser weiter aber es ist ja
nicht so dass man sich dann mit kind
verstecken muss also das geht ja
trotzdem alles und vor allem stand viel
praktischer wie die flasche weil du halt
nichts anrühren muss sondern alles
direkt bereit hast deswegen finde ich es
auch sehr schön auch so zum kuscheln ist
echt schön
ich genieße es
so langsam fängt die erlauf an zu
fremdeln ich stehe das mal aufgefallen
also manchmal wenn freunde von uns
kommen oder bekannte die sie noch nicht
so kennt dann weint sie auch mal wenn
sie es auf den arm nehmen
das mag sie dann hat es geht oder wenn
du mal nicht rasiert ist ja aber
ansonsten geht er ein sehr freundliches
kind muss ich dazu sei sie lacht ja sie
lacht immer unerzählte immer und ich
sehr lustig mit ihrem ja mama kann sie
ja schon sagen ja man könnte schon sagen
was mir mehr sagt sie mimi ist der
schnuller also auf türkisch und die
brust das hat sie auch gestern gesagt da
also wenn sie ruft wenn sie mich ruft
echte mama mama mama und wenn sie etwas
essen sagt sagt dieses youtube zwei
sachen die sie schon sagen kann gespannt
was als nächstes sagt ich tendiere auf
ablage also schwester wegen samira oder
einkommensteuererklärung ja sowas inter
hat ich will auch schon gespannt darauf
wie sie dann samira sagt weil die
kleinen sagen doch an die namen im
august eine groß gesehen hat nicht zum
beispiel immer lang in einem stadtteil
haben und die eine war hat sich sascha
genannt und die andere weiße na ja glaub
ich ja dann habe ich viele gefragt wie
es mir dann gerade körperlich geht also
gerade jetzt nach der geburt und ein
halbes jahr später
ich muss dazu sagen meine rückbildung
ich jetzt fast fertig als bei mir war es
kam immer was dazwischen und jetzt habe
ich noch zwei termine und dann bin ich
echt fertig und murat und ich wir wollen
dann auch mal mit der fitness mit
fitness anfang wie sie mal wieder gibt
noch nicht viele gemacht ich glaube
nicht doch
also ich hatte vorher auch mal weißem
ihrer schwangerschaft gemacht dieser
stelle machen
ja ja das müssen aber das müssen auch
machen also mit ganz gut so weiß merck
also ich sollte mal sport machen
ich hab halt manchmal rückenschmerzen
und also ich muss halt wieder fit werden
aber sonst geht es mir wirklich das
problem dass bei uns das fitnessstudio
neben globus ist unterschiedes beides
nebeneinander und da haben wir die
entscheidung
wir können nichts dafür dem seien direkt
nebeneinander gemacht
die verführung zu groß leider dann habe
ich einige gefragt wie wir mit der
ausstattung zufrieden sind also wie
immer noch zufrieden sind und es war
wirklich bisher wir bereuen gar nichts
also klar das babybett boote dann zu
klein da hat ja noch größere geholt aber
alles gut haben wir ein normales
kinderbett mit guitar die wickelkommode
ist perfekt auch gerade in baden wobei
ich mir da vielleicht noch im regal oder
so gewünscht hätte weil ich hatte keine
abstellmöglichkeit irgendwie außenrum
habe aber das ist alles nicht schlimm
und am samstag immer super zufrieden
zweimal regelrecht wenig wasser geholt
perfekt großes vermisst und beim
kinderwagen
da liegt sie jetzt immer noch in diesem
in der babyschale aber so langsam zieht
sie sich halt hoch also wenn sie
irgendwas greifen kann
dann zieht sie sich wirklich selber hoch
deswegen müssen wir langsam dann auf den
sportwagen aufsatz umschwenken und vor
allen dingen auch schön für sie dann
kann es auch mal raus gucken und einfach
mal beim spazierengehen auch die natur
beobachten
der kinderwagen ich super wirklichkeit
echt nur weiterempfehlen
wir sind auch oft unterwegs mit dem wir
waren neulich gerade in berlin hatten
wir den auch mit dabei dann darfst du
denn hier am flughafen immer bis zum
gate nehmen und dann packen die den ein
und danach bekommt stehen auch gleich
wieder flugreisen über sein
ach flughafen januar mit dir geflogen
wobei eigentlich schon das zweite mal
dass das erste mal war auf jeden fall
was echt super im flugzeug nach berlin
hin
hat sie erst mal die windeln voll
gemacht und dann der morast 08 schwitzt
die ach gott schwitzt die dabei war die
gattin die war von oben bis unten nass
also also nicht nach sondern er soll der
bogen gemacht gehabt das war heftig bis
zum nacken hoch dann habe ich sie auch
der flug
vom toilette habe ich sie entwickeln
müssen zwar ist katastrophal und du hast
an ihre kleidung vergessen ich habe sie
extra in seinen beutel rein dass ich sie
daheim waschen kann und er lässt es
einfach im flughafen im flugzeug liegt
ja und wir sollen das flugzeug kann ich
alles noch mal dabei geht es wäre heftig
gewesen
ja dann hat er noch den laptop natürlich
liege lasse den hammer zum glück wieder
hat ein ehrlicher finder hat ihn
abgegeben
auf dem rückweg wassernetze schön in
berlin
das war also ich muss echt sagen
frankfurter flughafen finde ich echt top
auch von der hygiene heer von die
mitarbeiter sind super nett und dann war
man in berlin und es war echt als ich
muss echt sagen ist ein echtes
schlimmste was ich bisher in meinem
leben erlebt habe wirklich also wir
waren da
beim check in war auch alles super und
dann in frankfurt kann ich halten oder
darfst du mit so einem kleinen kind vor
allem mit einem säugling halt immer auch
zu erst dann einsteigen weil du kannst
weil du eben den kinderwagen abgibt und
dann darf leben in ruhe einsteigen dich
hinsetzen ohne so viele menschen außen
herum und zwar in berlin jetzt zum
beispiel nicht so und da haben uns
hinten anstellen müssen für den
sicherheitscheck da kommt nimmst direkt
vor dem gate und dann haben uns da
angestellt ich glaube links genau weil
die frau uns gesagt hat wir uns links
anstellen und ein steak oder irgendwie
eine viertelstunde mit kind die meckert
die nörgelt und dann sagt vorne einer
könne sie sich nicht an stelle sie
müssen sich rechts anstellen weil der
kinderwagen links nicht durch passt als
immer nach rechts und haben da den einen
jungen mann darum gebeten dass wir eben
uns nicht noch mal hinten anstellen
müssen eine halbe stunde dass er uns
eben vor lässt dann sind wir nach vorne
gegangen dann haben hat der einst
teilweise noch ein kinderwagen
auseinanderbauen habe ich dann auch
gemacht und wollte ihn dann auf dieses
band drauflegen zum durch scannen und
dann stand da ein
bei dem sicherheits check also er hat
mit uns geredet das kann steht nicht
vorstellen
er hat ich glaube wir haben nach nach
seinem korb gebeten ich habe genau dem
moment können wir vielleicht bitte so
einen korb haben und dann hat er etwas
klappt mit rom endemol sie noch gar
nicht dran also so richtig pampig
geantwortet
und das ging dann die ganze zeit so dann
sagt haben sie überhaupt tickets und hat
danach unserem ticket eben gefragt was
heißt gefragt werden es eigentlich dumm
angemacht und da habe ich zu ihm gesagt
wäre es vielleicht möglich dass sie
vielleicht den umgangston bisschen
anpassen
es herrscht eine negative grundstimmung
weiß so richtig was das ist typisch
lehrerin
es war ein negativer grundstimmung ja ja
ich habe mir einfach damit ich was ganz
anderes
es existieren aber weiß dass da stehen
die leute unter behandelt die leute also
wirklich als wenn es irgendwie was wir
sich um menschen als ich finde es echt
unhöflich und er war richtig richtig
unhöflich und frech und da habe ich das
gesagt und vielleicht muss man dazu
sagen wenn man mit kind unterwegs ist
und der wickeltasche hat dann geht die
wickeltasche eigentlich nur durch den
nur durch den scanner und fertig weil du
darfst mit kind krems mitnehmen darf mit
kind getränke fürs kind und alles
mögliche mitnehmen und was stadtwerke
macht damit natürlich alles auspacken
lassen
dann hat der lask rehms untersucht und
da wartet eine creme mit dabei also sie
hat ja wirklich sehr starke hautprobleme
so dass er halt wirklich immer und wird
und offen wird und rein natürliche creme
die haben aus so neurodermitis und ich
muss es halt echt behandeln also ich hab
das in china samen creme ich hab eine
ringelblumen kriegen ohne tv also 100
prozent natürlich und die kommt aus der
schweiz kommt aus der schweiz
und es ist halt keine kinder creme
sondern es ist wirklich so eine
natürliche creme und bei der wird eben
herausgefunden dass sie wirklich super
bei neurodermitis auch wirkt und das ist
wirklich so also die l hat wirklich die
letzten fünf monate immer nur haut
probleme gehabt und zwar so heftig dass
der nacht aufgewacht ist und der ganze
partie zum beispiel blutig war weil
einfach die haut oft ohne vereitelt oder
veräußert und der ganze partie ist das
entweder mit einer voll oder mit blut
voll und es ist wirklich ganz ganz
schlimm wenn man sein kind dann nicht
helfen kann und wenn ich alles aus wo
wir den arzt gefragt und das waren nicht
die einzigen krems die geholfen haben
und deswegen habe ich die immer in
meiner wickeltasche und jetzt war halt
die eine creme de la creme 150
milliliter statt 100 und er wollte mir
die wegnehmen und habe ich ihnen das
eben erklärter gesagt ja das geht halt
nicht weil es in die cremes von ihr und
das eben das eine die ringelblume und
teebaumöl zum desinfizieren und für die
zellerneuerung da ist und die zia creme
total die hautbarriere
wieder auf vordermann bringen und wieder
so neutralisierten genau
und dann hat der gegner ich muss die
creme wegschmeißen
das geht nicht das ist extrem und ich
darf die mitnehmen in der wickeltasche
nach sydney das geht mit einem zu
mehrzweck jetzt müsst ihr euch
vorstellen ich stehe dann mit einem
kleinen baby und dann bist du schon
emotional und ich hatte echt als ich war
ich weiß dass ich so wütend einfach und
ich hab echt mit den trainern auch
kämpfen müssen habe ich es versucht zu
erklären dass jetzt einfach recht
hilflos bin und die wollten mich einfach
nicht durchlassen und und der ganze
verkehr blockiert dann hat sich noch
eine ein gemisch aus der schlange dann
hab ich das mal haben sich selber kinder
sagt hannes wahl so dann stehe ich total
ungerecht hilflos und dann sind also
leute die einfach ihre macht ausnutzen
und irgendwie ja das war echt das war
das war echt heftig und am ende war es
echt so ich habe dann gesagt dann hole
ich schnell was in der apotheke damit
ich so anfühlen kann wenigstens ein
bisschen dass ich ein bisschen was haben
das durfte ich dann auch nicht also die
haben echt nicht mit sich reden lassen
und hat sie gemeint ich soll meine
wickeltasche einchecken aber das kann ja
auch nicht mache ich mal vieles nicht
verstanden haben das ganze wirklich
verstanden weil die haben vielleicht
gedacht dass so eine tragödie nicht
abgeben ist noch nicht im kurs - die
medien um die firmen melden
und da habe ich gesagt ich kann meinen
wickeltasche eben auch nicht einchecken
weil ganz ehrlich beim hinflug hammer so
erlebt dass sie sich voll gemacht hat
bis obenhin das geht halt du kannst du
steine wickeltasche bei dir haben und
das haben die echt nicht verstanden und
ich glaube wir sind ja echt 20 oder 30
minuten gestanden haben mit denen
geredet
ich hab's versucht auf die gute art ich
bin und grün und kollege von ihm hat
sogar eingesehen kollegen schuldig
nochmal aber aber er wollte einfach
nicht da war echt hat einfach auf solo
musik macht seine macht aus spiel und
kriegt ihr nicht durch und das war halt
echt schlimm als ich stand echt dann
habe ich vor wut auch geweint und auch
weil ich mir dann gedacht hat mir stets
zu retten ich meine er hatte vielleicht
ein problem mit uns oder mit 70 oder
vielleicht hat er was schlechtes erlebt
an dem tag und hat praktisch an ihm
ausgelassen und das finde ich echt
heftig und am ende hat sie eben weil es
echt es war die diskussion war echt
wertloses das hat nichts gebracht und
dann
wollt ihr dass ich die creme wegschmeißt
und das wollte ich dann hat und dann
habe ich halt hin gestellt
ich konnte green hat wegschmeißen die
haben echt voll geweint also das war
echt schlimm auch wie die dann mit uns
umgegangen sind es war echt heftig auf
jeden fall wartest du unser erlebnis ich
hoffe das bleibt das einzige die creme
habe ich übrigens wieder bestellt die
kommt jetzt bald jetzt überbrücken wir
das ganze mit ringelblume und teebaumöl
wobei es jetzt echt die probleme wieder
hatte also es war echt schade aber naja
amazon schon was zu erzählen
hier ist also negative abschließen jetzt
gehen wir öfter spazieren lässt sich das
wetter wieder schön und ist auch echt
schön mit ihr neulich war mal im garten
bei unserer freundin haben es auf die
wiese gelegt mit einer decke und sagte
danach recht genossen also denn dann hat
einfach nur die umgebung beobachtet
immer schön und die samira passt auch
auf sie auf ganze also ich extrem sie
sagen ihr liebt sie und wenn sie mir aus
dem kindergarten lachen beide und arm
sich das ist so schön landesrecht
deshalb auch der mann hat gerade die ela
so auf seiner schulter sitzen
ich wollte nur sagen gestern hat sich
glaube ich fünf oder sechs mal gebrochen
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr gerne jeden
monat so ein update machen
ich denke dass sie bald anfängt für
krabbeln und jetzt nämlich einmal denn
ich glaube kleines mäuschen hat hunger
und ja dann sehen wir uns das nächste
mal wieder ein paar bilder zeigen wir
euch noch und vielen dank fürs
einschalten und wir sehen uns ganz bald
die ja die ja
laut ok